dylan cease ready to go to the mound and
he's on for his tenth start zra a good
one just over three
toughest part of this lineup is the top
three mullins mancini and santander and
if you can get them
usually you'll get the oreos
that's lined in the center field for a
base head and for cedric that's 17
first inning hits that leads the major
leagues
mancini steps in from the right 2-1 on
the way
inside oh god back of the elbow oh
well you hope it didn't get boned but
you know there's so many nerves there
so he's able to get the hands out of the
way but maybe not that back elbow right
here
yeah somewhere up in the tricep area
just says
all right of course yeah he's not
leaving it'll bring up switch hitting
freddie galvez with two down
he got him to swing through the slider
breaking ball
feeder from dylan cease to navigate
through
two on nobody out for a scoreless first
trey mancini looks like he has
some issues after getting hit by the
pitch
brian ebell out and it looks like trey's
night is over
and then on the hill it's bruce
zimmerman so there are the numbers
more hits than innings pitched a lot of
walks a lot of balls in the middle of
the plate
0-2 got him doesn't happen often only
had 17 strikeouts and 277
plate appearances and brings monkana up
to the plate
doesn't have to be great just has to be
something other than what he was looking
for
a switch hitting stevie wilkerson
oh he went right back to the slider
perfect pitch because it looks like a
strike to the last moment then dips out
of the zone
now chance cisco former second round
pick of the orioles
swing and a miss slider in the zone he
didn't necessarily want it there
but he punched himself a ticket anyway
one two three for dylan season this is a
turn the page night for
your mean mercedes who had a rough day
yesterday
oh mercedes unloads
a clothesline for a lead
do not blink
told you the ball goes in the air it's
going down to the ballpark and
that's probably one of those 3-0 pitches
you really like to see
a line drive rocket that didn't take
long at all to leave
and you're mean for the seventh time
hitting the ball out of the ballpark
garcia shifts up to second base two
going to the inning one-nothing white
sox
and mendic coming up to the plate
did he check it no we didn't ring them
up that says ted barrett the home plate
on fire
ryan mckenna is here because austin
hayes is on the injured list
it's a fast ball on that one it's a
bullseye
fourth strikeout in five batters balayka
takes a walk and santander will hit 2-2
struck him out good job by the clapping
section in row one over the wintrust
sign
fifth strikeout for dylan cease and now
yazmani grande will be the banner with a
man aboard
dude yeah breaking ball except he didn't
get the ground ball he struck him out
really nice pitch four strikeouts now
for zimmerman through two and a third
matergal still on at first base and
johan mankata
will be the batter there's another chain
drags it across the middle of the plate
so you just can't pick it up jose abreu
steps in
don't know is there enough room
yeah maybe yes ryan mckenna
right at the wall jumps up and keeps it
in the house
lake effect good thing it's a cool night
in chicago
freddie galvez now the batter
oh that's it well way back in right
field and it is gone
freddie galvez dials long distance
number seven
for freddy and we're tied at one oh the
old hanging curve ball
i'm talking about in minnesota joe jiraj
caggiola the room service hook what
would you like to hit
i'd like to have it belt high in the
middle of the plate
the knuckle curve ball doesn't knuckle
but it gets belted
and it brings up stewart
there is a changeup and down goes
stewart
strikeout number six for dylan so one
out in the white sox fourth and andrew
vaughn comes to the plate
and he got him down on strike strikeout
number six for zimmerman
so garcia board he can run speed at the
plate
bottom of the white sox order here and
then tie game 1-1
this one's hitting the air to left field
mckenna is there
and he makes the catch that one hit hard
but right at ryan mckenna
and a nice innie again for bruce
zimmerman chance
cisco left-handed hitting catcher leads
off the fifth
cease on three and two that's a fast
ball and that's a farewell
that's really what he was looking for
the entirety knew if he could get one
more high fastball
near the zone he was going to get him if
you can get by valencia and not have to
worry about santander until you lead off
in the sixth
that's a big plus there he goes the
slider eventually
takes care of business and the clapping
guys just did what they needed to do
the socks have something cooking now in
the fifth
two on with nobody out and here comes
grand doll
hits it hard there's one on the first
and a taylor made double play
good pitch just what the doctor ordered
for bruce zimmerman
i got choked up and now zimmerman goes
up against moncona 1-1 pitch
left field mckenna is there and that is
that so
the white sox get two on with nobody
down they can't score
here we go again the first two orioles
on and here is freddie galvez
struck him out fastball to the ceiling
nine
strikeouts for dylan sees tonight now
the switch hitting stevie wilkerson from
the left side
one two pitch swing and a miss strike
three
dylan cease has struck out ten
billy hamilton who will bat right-handed
first and second two outs
one one sixth inning on the ground
into center on two strikes
vaughn's coming home billy hamilton
2-1 and he takes it right back through
the middle
good piece of hitting sixth run driven
in by billy
it's the go ahead run in the ball game
oh two coming
can he strike out the side no
line to right field garcia charges in to
make the grab
and the inning's over so now he's got to
face abreu with runners at first and
second
jose left center field
madrigal's coming home
it's an rbi double it is
3-1 sox looking for more
your mean mercedes is here he is 7 for
17 against change-ups that's 4 12.
into center field a wayward change up
monkatta scores abreu follows
two run single for mercedes and it's 5-1
big night for your mean he's driven in
three orioles down to their last out
three and two
struck him out
the rhythm of 16 strikeouts a season
high for the sox pitching staff and a
series opener
5-1.